[Música]
hoy vamos a hablar de una polémica
práctica que cada vez se vuelve más
popular en occidente y que la podemos
ver frecuentemente en nuestras redes
sociales personas que viajan a países
africanos para hacer un voluntariado y
se fotografían rodeados de niños
huérfanos con carencias y viviendo en
condiciones bien precarias estas
personas llegan a estos lugares gracias
a una escuela un inglés incluso pagando
un programa de voluntariado para poder
participar algo que es conocido como 'el
volunturismo conversamos entonces con
julia codina ella es denunciante del
turismo de voluntariado él volunturismo
trabajadora humanitaria y cooperante
internacional que ha trabajado con amis
internacional también naciones unidas en
nairobi y líbano también la ocde como
analista juniors julia gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 para tener un contexto 1 y
después de ir desarrollando un poco este
tema como nace este volunturismo
pues el voluntarismo realmente es una
tendencia en alza pero que se empieza a
desarrollar a mediados de los 90 cuando
la tendencia era hacia un bueno había
toda una moda de turismo más responsable
ecoturismo se estaban explorando maneras
de hacer turismo pues más digamos
alternativas entonces es entonces cuando
empieza a surgir lo que acabará siendo
la industria no de las asociaciones que
comentaba es que después de pagar pues
un cierto una cierta cifra tienes la
experiencia de irte tres semanas a hacer
un voluntariado claro digamos julia que
en el papel y suena todo muy bien
digamos una persona que realmente quiere
ayudar a una población que lo necesita
pagando pues una cantidad de dinero y
para ya compartir con ellos a lo mejor
conocimiento y pues bueno todo ese tipo
de cosas pero cuando en realidad se
convierte en un problema cuando en
realidad se convierte como en algo
egoísta digamos una persona occidental
blanca diciendo pues bueno yo voy a ir
para un país africano me fotografió con
estos niños digo que hago obras sociales
voluntariado cuando realmente todo esto
se convierte en un problema y algo más
de yo ayudando que realmente ir a ayudar
a estas personas que necesitan claro
este es el problema básicamente la
resumido de albia que es la raíz de este
tipo de industria esto sí en sí ya es un
problema es decir las personas que van a
hacer este tipo de programas son
normalmente de media muy jóvenes y no
preparadas
es decir no con estudios para todas las
funciones que se supone que van a hacer
en el país del sur global evidentemente
en el que van es decir por ejemplo estar
en un orfanato enseñar inglés pasando
por construir vamos escuelas comedores
etcétera etcétera sin ningún tipo de no
de preparación para este tipo de
funciones que pasa pues que al final
digamos aunque pueda ser que venga de
una buena voluntad de estas personas
sincera
esta industria se mueve alrededor de los
de las necesidades del voluntario no de
la comunidad local a la que se supone
que se va a ayudar es decir
se sabe hay estudios además que este
tipo de prácticas tienen consecuencias
negativas no positivas sobre este tipo
de sobre las comunidades locales y aún
así las asociaciones y las industrias
digamos siguen en ello se se sabe que
hay una pérdida de empleo local porque
al final se suplanta con voluntarios no
preparados se sabe también que sobre
todo en el tema de los niños de los
orfanatos de enseñanza y esto puede
afectar al desarrollo cognitivo de los
niños de este programa porque
básicamente hay entran y salen
voluntarios continuamente que no están
preparados para la tareas educativas
etcétera etcétera
entre entre otras cosas entonces esto
esto en sí ya ya es un problema la
industria en sí digamos solo
retroalimentan
en las necesidades de los voluntarios y
no de la comunidad local que es quien
acaba sufriendo las consecuencias
negativas claro julia también pues qué
tan mal podemos estar como sociedad no
salvando a la gente que puede ir
realmente con una buena vocación una
gente como bien lo decías y preparada
para hacer estas labores de voluntariado
que está mal estamos como sociedad para
ir digamos a divertirnos con la pobreza
la carencia de una población no o sea
como como esto daña también
emocionalmente sobre todo a esta
población infantil huérfana vulnerada
maltratadas y pues estas personas que no
tienen ningún tipo de preparación van
solamente por una foto como vemos a esto
pues la verdad es que al final
evidentemente hay un tema de dinámicas
del norte global y el sur global hay un
tema también bueno todo lo que se llama
el síndrome de salvador blanco el hecho
de que a pesar de no tener preparación
para las tareas que una va a
agrupar en estos países después sepa o
crea que puede hacerlo mejor que la
gente de de esa comunidad del sur global
al final esto sólo refuerza esta
narrativa de que la gente del sur global
digamos necesita ayuda de del norte sea
cual sea es decir que incluso un
estudiante sin preparación va a hacerlo
mejor que una persona preparada de ese
sur global entonces al final no es tanto
unas ganas de ayudar pueden ser muy
nobles pero evidentemente el hecho de
que se tengan que ir a un país del psuv
global desde el norte pagando además una
cifra que digamos serviría para
seguramente empleados locales o
nacionales durante un año no porque
suelen ser bastante elevadas suelen ser
cifras en estándares europeos o
norteamericanos
esto ya indica bastante también que hay
una retribución social a este tipo de
actividades es decir la gente que van en
este tipo de voluntariados también a
veces se usa como moneda social todo el
tema de las fotografías en las redes
sociales no la persona que va a ayudar
rodeada de niños negros de niños de la
comunidad que sean esto al final pues
pues también también pasan cómo podemos
acabar digamos con esta mala práctica
julia digamos unas alternativas que
podamos que pueda tener la gente pues
que realmente si quiere ayudar a lo
mejor pasar por un proceso de
preparación yo lo pongo también en un
ejemplo muy fácil por muy buena voluntad
que yo tenga de operarle usted que
necesita una precisión urgente si yo
tengo esa preparación pues por muy buena
voluntad no puedo ayudarla de la mejor
mano de la mejor manera y pues
posiblemente voy a hacer el efecto
contrario y voy a ayudarla darle un daño
y también digamos hablando un poco en
las redes sociales que también lo
mencionaba que tanto las redes sociales
han expandido está practicada por moda
claro pues en primer lugar yo creo que
hay alternativas que para ayudar digamos
que no giran alrededor de uno mismo que
eso creo que es una de las de las bases
y lo que toca más el ego de las personas
es decir sabemos por ejemplo que
haciendo donaciones destinando el dinero
que pagarías para irte de voluntariado
se pueden contratar a trabajadores
locales para hacer el mismo trabajo y
además bien porque es que están
preparados para ello entonces estos
donaciones a organizaciones hagan ejes
organizaciones asociaciones que están
colaborando con estas comunidades
locales y es una forma de ayudar el
turismo mismo deja un impacto mejor
digamos que se deja dinero en las
comunidades se gastan como turista en
ese país y no se suplanta trabajo no hay
digamos no no no no hay una serie de
consecuencias negativas que cosas en un
turismo
y contestando también a tu pregunta
sobre el tema de las redes sociales
básicamente yo creo que sí es decir la
industria en sí ya era grande pero
evidentemente con instagram tweet y otro
tipo de redes sociales tick tock por
ejemplo se ha hecho muy visible el tema
de las dinámicas sobre sobre el terreno
no es las redes se llenan al final de
fotos de los vídeos de jóvenes
occidentales acomodados que viajan en
estos países empobrecidos que parece que
vayan para fotografías alimentando o
vistiendo estas familias pues que están
en una situación de pobreza o muy
frágiles y ésta está digamos este tipo
de fotografías y videos se convierten en
moneda social además las personas que
salen alrededor de los voluntarios
suelen no tener nombres se presentan
como esos otros no esos pobres pero
felices clones nos han ayudado a dar
cuenta que de los privilegiados que
somos al final es una
narrativa que solo
refuerza la del occidente salvador